From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，欢迎收听《美国生活》。
How many shows do you think you've started by saying, "So tell me what happened"?
你觉得你开始节目时用“所以，告诉我发生了什么”这句话，开了多少期节目？
It's actually very few.
其实没多少。
That's Chana Joffe-Walt, one of our producers. But this week, when she came into the studio with me, she did call this one correctly. What else could I say?
那是我们的制片人之一，查娜·乔夫-沃尔特。但本周，当她和我一起走进录音室时，她确实说对了这一点。我还能说什么呢？
So what did happen?
所以到底发生了什么？
OK, so this was a few weeks ago. Elementary and middle schools in East Harlem all got together in an auditorium for a talent show, a school talent show. So little kids are coming up to the stage to do orchestra performances and band and dance performances.
好吧，那是几周前的事。东哈莱姆区的小学和初中生们聚集在一个礼堂里参加才艺表演，学校的才艺表演。所以小孩子们上台进行管弦乐表演、乐队表演和舞蹈表演。
And at the end of the night, there's one more act on the program. It says "special surprise performance." And a drag queen comes out on stage, a grown-up. She's wearing this long, red wig and a black sequined leotard that has sheer arms with feathers around her wrists. And she comes out and does an Iris Chacón number, this Puerto Rican icon.
在表演结束时，节目单上还有一个节目。上面写着“特别惊喜表演”。然后一位变装皇后走上舞台，是个成年人。她戴着一顶长长的红假发，穿着一件黑色亮片连体衣，袖子是透明的，手腕处有羽毛。她走出来，表演了波多黎各偶像艾丽丝·查孔的曲目。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
And this is the sound of that?
这就是那个声音吗？
So this is the sound of that. This is actually the sound of when she gets down on the ground and rolls over onto all fours then rolls back onto her back and puts her two legs up in the air and then opens them. And you can see her underwear.
这就是那个声音。这其实是她趴在地上，翻身成四肢着地，然后又翻回背上，双腿向上并在空中张开时的声音。你可以看到她的内裤。
[WILD LAUGHTER]
[疯狂的笑声]
So just to be clear, there are elementary school kids here?
为了明确起见，那里有小学生在场吗？
Yes! Yes. This is a school performance. There are tons of kids. And on the program, it doesn't say who this person is, but it turns out a lot of people in this school know this person because he is a well-known dad in the school. He's the president of the PTA. Longtime president. This is actually his very last term as PTA president. He's the outgoing PTA president.
有！有的。这是一场学校演出。有很多孩子。节目单上没写这个人是谁，但事实证明，学校里的很多人都认识这个人，因为他是学校里一位有名的父亲。他是家长教师协会（PTA）的主席。长期担任主席。这实际上是他作为PTA主席的最后一届任期了。他是即将卸任的PTA主席。
Chana tried to reach the guy, but never talked to him. She actually heard about this story in a tabloid newspaper, The Daily News, under this headline--
查娜试图联系这个人，但从未和他谈过。她实际上是在一份小报《每日新闻》上听说的这个故事，标题是——
"Parents Horrified After Man Performs Surprise Drag Show at Manhattan School Talent Event." And that article has descriptions like, "Parents said families' laughter turned to disbelief and then dismay as Quinones"-- the PTA dad-- "opened his mouth and exercised his tongue in a suggestive manner while lip-syncing the Chacn number."
“男子在曼哈顿学校才艺活动中表演突袭式变装秀，家长们感到震惊。”那篇文章有这样的描述：“家长们说，当基尼奥内斯——那位PTA爸爸——在对口型演唱查孔的歌曲时，张开嘴并以暗示性的方式活动舌头，家庭们的笑声变成了难以置信，随之而来的是沮丧。”
School talent show in Manhattan taking a raunchy turn--
曼哈顿的学校才艺表演变得低俗——
So the story spreads to TV. It has a brief, enthusiastic moment on local TV.
所以这个故事传到了电视上。它在当地电视台上获得了一个简短而热烈的瞬间。
This outlandish drag performance, put on by the PTA president--
这场由PTA主席上演的奇异变装表演——
And all the TV reporters talked to this same mother, the one who complained about it.
所有的电视记者都采访了同一位母亲，就是那位投诉此事的母亲。
He laid on his back. He raised his legs. Opened his legs wide open. What made you, in your head, think that that was appropriate for elementary school students?
他躺在背上。他抬起腿。把双腿张得很大。你脑子里怎么会认为这适合小学生？
Mrs. Morales' report card for both the school and the district? An F and a triple X.
莫拉莱斯夫人给学校和学区打出的成绩单是什么？一个F和一个三级X。
That is perfect local TV newswriting, I have to say.
不得不说，那是完美的当地电视新闻写作。
It was like she was waiting for the chance.
就好像她一直在等待机会一样。
Yeah.
是啊。
It was clear from some of the other coverage that lots of people in the school like this guy, know him really well, and that some people liked the performance.
从其他一些报道中可以看出，学校里很多人都喜欢这个家伙，对他很了解，而且有些人喜欢这场表演。
The performance was spot-on. Spot on. He did everything like Iris Chacn would have done.
表演非常到位。非常到位。他做得就像艾丽丝·查孔会做的那样。
Was it OK in this environment?
在这种环境下，这样做合适吗？
I think they've seen a lot worse.
我想他们见过更糟糕的。
Have they? From East Harlem, Vanessa Murdock, CBS2 News.
是吗？来自东哈莱姆区，凡妮莎·默多克，CBS2新闻报道。
OK. So you heard about this thing that happened, and it interested you. It hit something in you, and your reaction was different.
好的。你听说了这件事，这引起了你的兴趣。它触动了你内心的某些东西，你的反应与众不同。
It totally captivated me. I thought about him so much. And I did not have any of those reactions. It didn't feel like it was super scandalous. I just felt totally taken by it because I spend a lot of time watching shows like this. I have two young kids. I have younger sisters. I do reporting in schools.
它完全吸引了我。我非常关注他。我没有任何那种反应。我觉得这并不算特别丑闻。我只是被它完全吸引了，因为我花了很多时间看这样的节目。我有两个年幼的孩子。我有年幼的姐妹。我在学校里做报道。
In fact, in that same month as the drag performance, Chana went to a preschool end of the year ceremony and performance, a kindergarten stepping up ceremony, a middle school graduation, a middle school talent show, and a magic after-school program performance.
事实上，就在变装表演的那个月，查娜参加了一个学前班的年终庆典和表演、幼儿园结业典礼、初中毕业典礼、初中才艺表演以及课后魔术项目表演。
That was just June. And that was when I saw this video. And I feel like I spend most of the time sitting through those shows just waiting for something like this to happen, like maybe something exciting and unexpected will happen.
那只是六月。而那是我看到这段视频的时候。我觉得我大部分时间都在这些节目中坐着，只是等待着像这样的事情发生，也许会发生一些令人兴奋和意想不到的事情。
Because those shows are pretty boring.
因为那些节目真的很无聊。
They're mind-numbing. And then there's the one tiny, tiny moment where your kid does something and no matter what they do, that's amazing, but then you have to continue to perform to be as amazed at every other kid for the next, sometimes, three hours. So all I ever hope for is something in one of these shows will happen that is unexpected. And I know this is not the surprise that people in this school wanted. Like, I get that. It is sexual. There are children. It's drag. It's gay, which is probably even scarier to some parents. That whole thing, I understand. I get that.
它们让人麻木。然后有一个极其微小的瞬间，你的孩子做了一些事情，无论他们做什么，那都是了不起的，但随后你必须在接下来的、有时长达三个小时的时间里，继续表现出对其他每一个孩子同样惊叹的样子。所以我唯一希望的就是在这些节目中能发生一些意想不到的事情。我知道这不是这所学校里的人想要的惊喜。比如，我明白这一点。它是色情的。有孩子在场。这是变装。这是同性恋，这对一些家长来说可能更可怕。整个这件事，我理解。我明白。
But.
但是。
But I feel like the thing I liked about it is not just that it's surprising, but it's him. Like, it is this guy. This is a real thing that is happening. He is getting on stage and sharing a part of himself with his community.
但我感觉我喜欢它的原因不仅仅是因为它令人惊讶，而是因为那是他。就像，这是真实发生的。他走上舞台，与社区分享他自己的一部分。
He's being real.
他表现得很真实。
He's being real. Yeah, he's being real. And that's what you want, right? He's kind of modeling the thing that you want from these shows, is that some kid will get up there and do some weird, strange thing that is just themselves, that is just true, just feels like who they are.
他表现得很真实。是的，他表现得很真实。这就是你想要的，对吧？他有点像在模拟你从这些节目中想要的东西，那就是某个孩子会走上台去做一些奇怪的、陌生但只是他们自己的事情，那是真实的，感觉就像他们本来的样子。
You're saying that because you've actually seen that?
你这么说是因为你真的见过吗？
Well, I was thinking, after watching this video, that one of the most moving things I've ever seen on stage, actually, was at a school talent show years ago that I hadn't thought about for a long time, where this girl got up. She was maybe 10, and she was super shy. She was like one of those kids that you're kind of surprised that she's getting on stage in the first place. And she seemed nervous. And then the music comes on and she very confidently moves into this strange interpretive dance of Billie Jean, where she's--
嗯，我在想，在看了这段视频后，我曾经在舞台上见过的最感人的事情之一，其实是几年前在一次学校才艺表演上，我很久没想过这件事了，当时那个女孩上台了。她可能10岁，非常害羞。她就像那种让你很惊讶她居然会站上舞台的孩子。她看起来很紧张。然后音乐响起，她非常自信地进入了这段奇怪的《Billie Jean》现代舞，在那里她——
Michael Jackson.
迈克尔·杰克逊。
Yeah, Michael Jackson, but she's not wearing a fedora. She's wearing a beret. The most striking part of it was just that she was super confident. And she's kind of leaning over like she's like an elderly person and moving her arms back and forth, like octopus arms. I remember she had braids, purple braids, that were also swinging back and forth. And people lost it. Everybody went totally crazy for her. Not because she was good. She wasn't doing the moves very well. But it was her. This was a true thing that was happening. This was a person who the stage gave her a place to perform something that she's interested in, something who she really is, something that just is real, is true.
是的，迈克尔·杰克逊，但她没戴软呢帽。她戴着一顶贝雷帽。最引人注目的是她超级自信。她有点像个老人一样弯着腰，双臂来回摆动，就像章鱼的手臂一样。我记得她扎着辫子，紫色的辫子，也跟着来回摆动。人们疯了。每个人都为她彻底疯狂。不是因为她跳得好。她的动作做得不怎么样。但那是她。这是一件正在发生的真实的事情。这是一个舞台给了她一个表演空间的人，她对某件事感兴趣，那是她真实的样子，是一些真实、纯粹的东西。
Well, today on our radio program, that is what we aspire to. That is where we're heading. We are leaving behind the obligatory, the half-baked, the phoned-in, the superficial. We leave behind the meh. And we turn our backs on the word "meh" because the word "meh" is meh itself. And instead, we have stories of people seeking out what is real, what is true in some places you might not expect that. What you find, what you feel, what you know to be real. Stay with us.
好吧，今天在我们的广播节目中，这就是我们要追求的。这就是我们要前进的方向。我们将抛弃那些义务性的、半生不熟的、敷衍了事的、肤浅的东西。我们抛弃“平庸”。我们拒绝“平庸”这个词，因为“平庸”这个词本身就很平庸。相反，我们讲述人们寻找真实、寻找在某些意想不到的地方所呈现的真相的故事。你所发现的、你所感受的、你所知道的真实。请继续收听。
Act One, How I Learned to Start Worrying and Fear the Bomb.
第一幕，我是如何学会停止担忧并害怕炸弹的。
You probably heard a few weeks ago North Korea fired an intercontinental ballistic missile, one powerful enough, news reports said, to reach Alaska with a nuclear warhead. And it was big news. People were shocked, North Korea being on the verge of being able to nuke us. Which was strange to one of our producers here at our show, David Kestenbaum. He used to be a reporter for National Public Radio.
你可能几周前听说朝鲜发射了一枚洲际弹道导弹，新闻报道称其威力足以携带核弹头到达阿拉斯加。这是个大新闻。人们感到震惊，朝鲜处于能够向我们投掷核弹的边缘。这对我们节目的一位制片人大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆来说很奇怪。他曾经是国家公共电台的记者。
When I was at NPR, one of the things I helped cover was nuclear weapons policy around the world. And when it came to North Korea, I've talked to people, various experts, and they would say something like, we have a decade. It's going to take them a while to get there.
我在NPR时，我负责报道的内容之一是世界各地的核武器政策。当谈到朝鲜时，我和各种专家谈过，他们会说类似“我们还有十年时间”的话。他们要达到那个目标还需要一段时间。
And then how long ago was that?
那是多久以前的事了？
About a decade ago.
大约十年前。
So right on time.
所以正好准时。
We're exactly on schedule.
我们完全按计划进行。
Right. We said that 10 years ago it would take 10 years. Here we are.
对。我们十年前说过这需要十年。现在我们到了。
Yeah.
是的。
And I just thought, how did we let this happen? How did we get here?
我只是在想，我们怎么会让这种情况发生？我们是怎么走到这一步的？
How did we get here? All of us, David included, were not being real with ourselves about what was going on with North Korea. To remedy that, and to get some answers about how we let this happen, David turned to a trusted source on iTunes.
我们是怎么走到这一步的？我们所有人，包括大卫，在朝鲜问题上都没有对自己诚实。为了纠正这一点，并就我们如何让这种情况发生得到一些答案，大卫转向了iTunes上的一个可信来源。
Quick warning. There are a couple curse words in his story and in one other story in today's program that we have unbeeped here on the internet version of our program. If you don't want to hear those words, maybe you're listening with kids, there is a beeped version at our website. Here's David.
简短警告。他的故事和今天节目中的另一个故事中有几个脏话，我们在我们节目的互联网版本中没有将其消音。如果你不想听到那些话，也许你是和孩子们一起听的，我们的网站上有消音版本。这是大卫的报道。
Back when I was covering this stuff, we reporters all had a short list of people we would call to comment when there was news. And often, this thing would happen. When the interview started and we were recording, the person would get super serious because, you know, nuclear weapons. The world could end. The thing is, that is not how a lot of them actually talked about this stuff. The way they actually talked off mic was more like this.
当我还在报道这些事情的时候，我们记者都有一个简短的名单，在有新闻时我们会打电话给名单上的人评论。通常情况下，会发生这种情况。采访开始录音时，对方会变得超级严肃，因为你知道，核武器。世界可能会毁灭。问题是，这并不是他们谈论这些事情的真实方式。他们在麦克风外谈论的方式更像是这样。
Kim Jong Un posed with a nuclear weapon!
金正恩拿着核武器拍照！
We saw everything.
我们看到了所有东西。
This is from a podcast called Arms Control Wonk. It's helped me understand North Korea in a way that I never had. It was started by Jeffrey Lewis. He's a nuclear policy expert and also director of the East Asia Nonproliferation Program at the Middlebury Institute of International Studies at Monterey. He says, frankly, he was tired of all the formal diplomat speak.
这是来自一个叫《军备控制专家》的播客。它以我从未有过的方式帮助我了解朝鲜。它是由杰弗里·刘易斯发起的。他是一位核政策专家，也是蒙特雷明德国际研究所东亚防扩散项目主任。他说，坦率地说，他厌倦了所有正式的外交辞令。
I was giving a talk to the board of Middlebury College. This was a pretty big talk to have to give to show off the research of the center. And at some point, we were talking about a photograph of Kim Jong Un that had been digitally altered. Something had been done to his ears. And we see this a lot. And what I said was, they always fuck with his ears. And everybody was looking at me like, uh, did you just say that?
我当时在给明德学院的董事会做演讲。这是一个相当重要的演讲，用来展示该中心的研究成果。在某个时候，我们正在谈论一张金正恩被数字化修改过的照片。他的耳朵被做了手脚。我们经常看到这种情况。我说的是，他们总是乱搞他的耳朵。每个人都看着我，好像在说，呃，你刚才说了什么？
Wait. Why do they mess with his ears?
等等。他们为什么要乱搞他的耳朵？
We think they make them smaller. So I guess he feels like his ears are too big? I don't know. It's a weird thing to be worried about.
我们认为他们把耳朵改小了。所以我猜他觉得自己的耳朵太大了？我不知道。担心这个真是件奇怪的事。
That is the kind of microanalysis Jeffrey and the people he works with do-- not just with Kim Jong Un's ears. Whenever there are new photos of a missile or there's been a nuclear test, they dig through the data in a really smart way. I've even gotten attached to the theme song, which has this upbeat time bomb thing going on. It's from a German punk band.
这就是杰弗里和他共事的人所做的微观分析——不仅仅是针对金正恩的耳朵。每当有新的导弹照片或进行核试验时，他们都会以非常聪明的方式挖掘数据。我甚至对主题曲产生了感情，它有一种欢快的定时炸弹的感觉。它来自一支德国朋克乐队。
You are listening to the Arms Control Wonk podcast, the leading podcast on arms control, nonproliferation, and disarmament.
你正在收听的是《军备控制专家》播客，这是关于军备控制、防扩散和裁军的领先播客。
One of the things they spend a lot of time trying to sort out on the podcast is what is real. It can be hard to tell. North Korea will put out some propaganda video saying, "Another successful missile launch." But if you look closer, it is not always what it seems. Here's a clip from the podcast where Jeffrey is talking to one of his grad students.
他们在播客中花了很多时间试图弄清楚什么是真实的。这很难判断。朝鲜会发布一些宣传视频，声称“又一次成功的导弹发射”。但如果你仔细看，它并不总是看起来的那样。这是播客中的一段片段，杰弗里正在和他的研究生交谈。
So this Korean group in Japan that releases all this North Korean propaganda released a little video which they claimed to be footage of the submarine launch but turned out was not.
所以这个在日本的韩国团体发布了所有这些朝鲜宣传材料，发布了一段小视频，他们声称是潜艇发射的镜头，但事实证明并非如此。
Launching a missile from a submarine would be a big deal because, if they can put a nuclear weapon on a sub, it's harder to destroy. And they might be able to sneak it closer to US shores. So the video gets posted online and Jeffrey says, looks pretty impressive.
从潜艇发射导弹将是一件大事，因为如果他们能把核武器放在潜艇上，就更难摧毁了。而且他们可能能够将其悄悄靠近美国海岸。所以视频发布在网上，杰弗里说，看起来相当令人印象深刻。
They basically show the top of the tube, where the missile is, underwater. And the hatch is open, and the missile pops up, and it goes rushing through the water.
他们基本上展示了管子的顶部，也就是导弹所在的水下位置。舱口打开，导弹弹出来，在水中冲刺。
But the grad student, Dave Schmerler, looks at this and thinks something doesn't seem right. So he just starts googling submarine launch footage. And one of the first things he finds on YouTube is this thing that looks very similar. And I mean very similar. Jeffrey showed me the video clip so I could compare.
但研究生戴夫·施默勒看着这个，觉得有些不对劲。所以他开始在谷歌上搜索潜艇发射的镜头。他在YouTube上发现的第一件事就是看起来非常相似的东西。我是说非常相似。杰弗里给我看了视频片段，以便我比较。
OK, so here's the North Korean one.
好的，这是朝鲜的那个。
[SPEAKING KOREAN]
[韩语演讲]
Oh, so it's footage from underwater.
哦，所以这是水下的镜头。
Yeah.
是的。
Wow.
哇。
It's this crazy underwater.
这是疯狂的水下镜头。
That's impressive.
这令人印象深刻。
It looks cool, right?
看起来很酷，对吧？
Yeah, yeah. It looks cool.
是的，是的。看起来很酷。
OK. So here's the other one.
好的。这是另一个。
--and a new submarine, faster, quieter--
——以及一艘新的潜艇，更快、更安静——
The other one is an old video of a US missile launch.
另一个是美国导弹发射的旧视频。
They took our footage.
他们用了我们的镜头。
--then the Poseidon, or C3 missile--
——然后是波塞冬或C3导弹——
Yeah. It's the same, right?
是的。是一样的，对吧？
I mean, it's exactly the same.
我的意思是，完全一样。
Oh, yeah. And they do this all the time.
哦，是的。他们一直这样做。
Do you think they actually launched a missile from a submarine that day?
你认为他们那天真的从潜艇上发射了导弹吗？
I think they may have popped up a missile from a barge, but I don't think it flew. I don't think it worked. I don't think it involved a submarine.
我认为他们可能从驳船上弹出了导弹，但我不认为它飞了。我不认为它起作用了。我不认为它涉及潜艇。
So basically, none of what they were saying happened happened?
所以基本上，他们说的发生的事情根本没有发生？
Right.
对。
You can see why it would be easy not to take them too seriously. The thing that Jeffrey has noticed about North Korea's claims, though, is that there is always some truth to them. Like, OK, maybe they didn't launch a missile from a sub, but they're working on it. And maybe that wasn't an actual hydrogen bomb they tested, but it was probably something else worrying.
你可以看出为什么很容易不把他们太当回事。然而，杰弗里注意到朝鲜的主张中总是包含一些事实。比如，好吧，也许他们没有从潜艇上发射导弹，但他们正在努力。也许他们测试的不是真正的氢弹，但可能是一些令人担忧的其他东西。
In listening to this podcast, you realize how relentlessly the North Koreans have been working at this stuff over the years. It's this running audio diary of North Korea's military program. Missile test after missile test. This is from 2014.
在收听这个播客时，你意识到多年来朝鲜在这些事情上是多么不懈地努力。这是朝鲜军事项目的运行音频日记。导弹试验一个接一个。这是2014年的。
The pace at which they are testing is totally unprecedented. It's a little bit hard to count them all up because there have been so many tests. More of those tests this year than certainly any year I know, and maybe than ever. I mean, it is a lot of missile tests.
他们测试的步伐是完全史无前例的。因为测试太多了，很难把它们都数清楚。今年测试的次数肯定比我所知的任何一年都要多，也许比以往任何一年都多。我的意思是，有很多导弹试验。
I had always imagined we'd figure something out. We'd reach some agreement with North Korea, or we'd do something before things got this bad. How did we get here? This was a half hour discussion, but I'll distill it down for you.
我一直以为我们会想出办法。在事情变得这么糟糕之前，我们会与朝鲜达成某种协议，或者我们会做些什么。我们是怎么走到这一步的？这是一次半小时的讨论，但我为你提炼一下。
Jeffrey says our best chance to stop this was probably in the late '90s. This was before North Korea had nuclear bombs. Jeffrey points out it's always easier to get someone to give up something that they don't have yet. The US-- this was the Clinton administration-- and North Korea had negotiated something called the Agreed Framework.
杰弗里说我们阻止这一点的最佳机会可能是在90年代末。那是在朝鲜拥有核弹之前。杰弗里指出，让人放弃他们还没有拥有的东西总是更容易的。美国——当时是克林顿政府——和朝鲜谈判达成了一个名为《框架协议》的东西。
North Korea would shut down its nuclear reactor that could produce plutonium for bombs. In exchange, they would get two new nuclear power plants, a different type that would make electricity and would be harder to get plutonium out of for bombs. North Korea would also get fuel oil to tide them over until the new reactors could be built. And we'd try to resume normal economic and diplomatic relations. But some Republican members of Congress felt like we were appeasing what was a brutal regime, so ending sanctions was a nonstarter. We were slow in fulfilling our part of the deal. Oil shipments were late. There were also delays building the new reactors, which were to be paid for mostly by South Korea and Japan.
朝鲜将关闭其可以生产炸弹用钚的核反应堆。作为交换，他们将获得两座新的核电站，这种类型更难从中获取制造炸弹的钚。朝鲜还将获得燃料油以度过难关，直到新反应堆建成。我们将尝试恢复正常的经济和外交关系。但一些共和党国会议员觉得我们是在安抚一个残暴的政权，所以结束制裁是免谈的。我们在履行交易方面很慢。石油运输延迟了。建设新反应堆也有延误，这主要由韩国和日本出资。
On the North Korea side, it looked like they might still be working on a bomb. In 2002, the CIA said North Korea was building centrifuges, big spinning tubes that could enrich uranium. They certainly had them by 2010, when a US weapons scientist, Sig Hecker, was invited over for a visit. The North Koreans actually had him over a bunch. They took him to this huge building as long as a football field. It was filled with centrifuges. This is from a talk he's given.
在朝鲜方面，看起来他们可能仍在制造炸弹。2002年，中情局称朝鲜正在建造离心机，即可以浓缩铀的大型旋转管。到2010年，当美国武器科学家西格·赫克受邀访问时，他们肯定已经拥有了这些。朝鲜人其实邀请他去过很多次。他们带他去了这栋像足球场一样长的大楼。里面装满了离心机。这是他的一次演讲片段。
When I went up to the second floor and I looked into the centrifuge hall through this glass, I said, wow, 2,000 centrifuges in there. They must have noticed that my jaw dropped all the way down to here. It was just totally mind-boggling. I thought it was more like a garage operation, where they had made a few of their own or whatever. Instead, this was different. Control room, all flat-paneled LEDs display, flat-panel computers. It was unbelievable.
当我走到二楼，透过这块玻璃看着离心机大厅时，我说，哇，里面有2000台离心机。他们一定注意到我的下巴掉到了这里。这简直令人难以置信。我以为这更像是车库操作，他们自己做了几个或者别的什么。相反，这是不同的。控制室，所有平面LED显示屏，平板电脑。这令人难以置信。
Jeffrey Lewis says, looking back, we should have found some way to make the agreement work.
杰弗里·刘易斯说，回顾过去，我们应该找到某种方法让协议奏效。
We blew it. Yeah, we blew it in a pretty comprehensive, complex way. They didn't help things because they didn't trust us, and they definitely-- cheated is a word with a bunch of moral tones to it, but they didn't make it easy. So now, I think we're at a point where they have these nuclear weapons, and they're not giving them up.
我们搞砸了。是的，我们以一种相当全面、复杂的方式搞砸了。他们没有提供帮助，因为他们不信任我们，而且他们绝对——作弊是一个带有道德色彩的词，但他们并没有让事情变得简单。所以现在，我认为我们处于一个他们拥有这些核武器且不会放弃它们的阶段。
There have been attempts at negotiation over the years, but usually the US has insisted that North Korea give up its nukes, basically wanting to go back to those days before North Korea had a bomb. North Korea, understandably, has said no. Jeffrey says Kim Jong Un believes that, as long as he has nukes and missiles to launch them, no one will mess with him. And he's kind of right.
多年来曾尝试过谈判，但通常美国坚持要求朝鲜放弃核武器，基本上是想回到朝鲜拥有炸弹之前的日子。朝鲜理所当然地说不。杰弗里说金正恩相信，只要他拥有核武器和发射导弹，就没人会来找他麻烦。他算是有道理的。
When North Korea did its first nuclear test in 2006, it was basically a dud. Jeffrey says his reaction at the time was, they are the worst ever at this. But they've gotten better and done more tests since then.
当朝鲜在2006年进行第一次核试验时，基本上是个哑弹。杰弗里说他当时的反应是，他们在这方面是有史以来最差的。但从那时起，他们已经改进并进行了更多的测试。
North Korea has been pretty clear about what it wants to be able to do with its bombs. A few years ago, North Korea released this propaganda photo. It was taken inside some military facility. And in the background, on the wall, was this map. If you zoomed in, you could see these lines that terminate at cities in the US, presumably the ones North Korea would like to be able to strike with nuclear missiles. The photo is well-known in analyst circles. It's sometimes called the Map of Death. And then earlier this year, North Korea released an even more remarkable photo-- Kim Jong Un posing with this shiny thing.
朝鲜已经很清楚它想用炸弹做什么。几年前，朝鲜发布了这张宣传照片。它是在某个军事设施内拍摄的。在背景的墙上，有这张地图。如果你放大看，你可以看到这些终点指向美国城市的线，大概就是朝鲜希望能够用核导弹打击的那些城市。这张照片在分析圈里很有名。它有时被称为死亡地图。今年早些时候，朝鲜发布了一张更引人注目的照片——金正恩拿着这个闪亮的东西拍照。
I was like, holy shit, that's a nuclear weapon. Foreign leaders do not pose with nuclear weapons. That is just not a thing.
我当时心想，天哪，那是核武器。外国领导人不会拿着核武器拍照。这根本不是一回事。
Just describe what the photo looks like.
描述一下这张照片是什么样的。
Yeah. He's in a missile plant. And he's in this crazy getup, which is kind of an allusion to his grandfather. So he's got like the Russian fur hat and this big coat with this fur collar. And he got these silly eyeglasses that sometimes he wears. And so he looks ridiculous. And in front of him is this spherical object. Actually, it's not spherical. It's a specific type of geometric pattern, but whatever. It's this big-- it looks like a disco ball.
是的。他在一个导弹工厂里。他穿着这套疯狂的服装，有点暗示他的祖父。他戴着那种俄罗斯皮帽，穿着这种大衣领的大外套。他戴着这种愚蠢的眼镜，有时他会戴。所以他看起来很荒谬。在他面前是这个球形物体。其实，它不是球形的。它是一种特定的几何图案，但随便吧。它是这个大的——看起来像个迪斯科球。
If that's an actual bomb, he says it's small enough to fit on a missile. This picture, of course, merited an entire podcast and included a rant Jeffrey delivers in lots of them about denial.
如果那是一个真正的炸弹，他说它足够小，可以装进导弹里。这张照片当然值得整个播客讨论，并包括杰弗里在很多播客中关于否认的咆哮。
You know what my favorite part about this whole conversation has been?
你知道我最喜欢整个对话的哪一部分吗？
What?
什么？
I have noticed that there is this incredible reluctance to believe that the North Koreans have actually developed nuclear weapons. So every time the North does a nuclear test-- you know, I have some South Korean reporter asking me like, well, is it possible that they just filled a mountain with conventional explosives? And when you step back from it, it's like, oh, wow. They've done four nuclear tests. Three times they have paraded road mobile ICBMs down the streets of Pyongyang. They put up a map of the United States with targets on it that said Mainland Strike Plan. And now Kim Jong Un is standing in front of-- it's probably a mockup, but nonetheless-- a nuclear weapon. And people are like, what do you think they're saying? It seems pretty frickin clear to me.
我注意到人们有一种难以置信的抵触情绪，不愿相信朝鲜真的研制出了核武器。所以每次朝鲜进行核试验——你知道，我有韩国记者问我，好吧，他们是否可能只是用常规炸药填满了山？当你退后一步看时，就像是，哦，哇。他们已经进行了四次核试验。三次他们在大街上游行了公路移动洲际弹道导弹。他们贴出了一张带有目标的美国地图，上面写着“大陆打击计划”。现在金正恩站在——这可能是一个模型，但尽管如此——核武器前面。人们说，你认为他们在说什么？对我来说，这非常清楚。
Jeffrey says, through all this, we have kind of underestimated the North Koreans maybe because they seem so goofy. Or maybe because it's easier to do that than to admit the truth.
杰弗里说，通过所有这些，我们有点低估了朝鲜人，也许是因为他们看起来太傻了。或者也许是因为承认真相比这更容易。
I actually had a big argument with-- I shouldn't call it an argument. I had a big conversation with a Japanese government official about this, where we were talking about, oh, I don't know, some missile test. I mean, there have been so many at this point. And he was sort of saying like, well, we're going to have to give sanctions some more time to work. I'm just like, you don't have more time. It's like, no, I think we'll give it a couple of years and, you know, we'll see where we are. And it's like, in a couple of years, they could have a thermonuclear weapon on an ICBM. Maybe it won't be all worked out. Maybe there will still be some problems with it, but I don't think you've got a couple of years, chief.
我其实和一位日本政府官员就此进行了激烈的争论——我不应该称之为争论。我进行了深入的对话，我们当时正在谈论，哦，我不知道，某种导弹测试。我的意思是，此时此刻测试已经太多了。他有点像在说，嗯，我们将不得不给制裁更多时间来发挥作用。我只是说，你没有更多时间了。就好像，不，我认为我们会给它几年时间，你知道，我们会看看我们在哪里。就好像，几年后，他们可能会在洲际弹道导弹上拥有热核武器。也许它不会完全解决。也许仍然会有一些问题，但我不认为你有几年时间，头儿。
I was kind of beating him up, and he was taking it pretty well. And I think the reason he was taking it pretty well is because he's a government official. He's got a job to do. And I think he kind of knows that they don't actually know what the heck they're doing. But what kind of government trots out before its citizens and says, hey, you know this really tough problem that terrifies you? We don't have the slightest idea what to do. Nobody does that.
我有点在教训他，而他接受得相当好。我认为他接受得相当好是因为他是一名政府官员。他有一份工作要做。我认为他有点知道他们实际上不知道他们到底在做什么。但什么样的政府会走到公民面前说，嘿，你知道这个让你恐惧的棘手问题吗？我们一点也不知道该怎么办。没人会那么做。
Earlier this month, when North Korea, for the first time, tested an actual intercontinental ballistic missile that could reach Alaska, it was all over the news. Everyone was kind of freaking out.
本月早些时候，当朝鲜首次测试了一枚能够到达阿拉斯加的真正洲际弹道导弹时，新闻里全是这个。每个人都有点吓坏了。
The new provocation from North Korea.
来自朝鲜的新挑衅。
North Korea's recent test launch of a missile that could reach the US.
朝鲜最近试射了一枚能够到达美国的导弹。
This is North Korea's most successful missile test--
这是朝鲜最成功的导弹测试——
--which Kim Jong Un called a birthday gift to the US.
——金正恩称其为给美国的生日礼物。
But regular listeners to the podcast kind of knew it was coming because just two months ago, North Korea had tested a missile that went pretty damn far-- 1,300 miles up into space and back. So when the ICBM test actually came, I figured Jeffrey's reaction would be a shrug. Like, we told you so. But he was kind of shocked, too. Even though he knew it was coming, just the reality of it was shocking.
但播客的常客们大概知道它要来了，因为就在两个月前，朝鲜测试了一枚飞得非常远的导弹——飞入太空1300英里然后返回。所以当洲际弹道导弹测试真的来临时，我以为杰弗里的反应会是耸耸肩。就像，我们告诉过你。但他也有点震惊。尽管他知道它要来了，但这本身就是令人震惊的。
This one can hit the United States with a nuclear weapon. People keep saying Alaska, but that's people making themselves feel better. It demonstrated the range to go to Alaska. That doesn't mean that that is its maximum range. We've been modeling it, and it looks a lot better than that.
这一个可以用核武器击中美国。人们一直在说阿拉斯加，但那是人们让自己感觉好受些。它证明了去阿拉斯加的射程。这并不意味着那是它的最大射程。我们一直在建模，看起来比那个好得多。
Meaning it can go further?
意思是它可以飞得更远？
Yeah, it probably can hit New York.
是的，它可能可以击中纽约。
It probably can hit New York?
它可能可以击中纽约？
Yeah. This last one went seven times higher than the ISS.
是的。最后这次比国际空间站高七倍。
Seven times higher than the International Space Station?
比国际空间站高七倍？
Yeah, seven times higher.
是的，高七倍。
So this was significantly further than that other one?
所以这比另一个明显远得多？
Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. This is a hell of a missile.
哦，是的。哦，是的。这是一枚了不起的导弹。
It seems like North Korea might just keep doing this-- setting off bigger and bigger atomic bombs, launching huge missiles. Talking to Jeffrey, I realized I had this question. What exactly does North Korea want?
看起来朝鲜可能只会继续这样做——引爆越来越大的原子弹，发射巨大的导弹。和杰弗里谈话时，我意识到我有这个问题。朝鲜到底想要什么？
North Korea wants to be treated like a normal country.
朝鲜想要被当作一个正常的国家来对待。
Meaning what?
意味着什么？
Meaning diplomatic recognition and no sanctions and Kim Jong Un gets invited to state dinners. They just want to be-- they want the Kim family to be treated like a legitimate leadership.
意味着外交承认和没有制裁，金正恩被邀请参加国宴。他们只是想要——他们希望金氏家族被当作一个合法的领导层来对待。
And that is the impossible spot we are in. This is a government the United Nations Human Rights Council says is guilty of crimes against humanity, including extermination, murder, enslavement, torture, imprisonment, rape. The list goes on. Kim Jong Un's people are starving. They're cut off from the outside world. We just ignore all that? Invite him to the White House for a state dinner? Jeffrey comes down firmly on one side of that question.
这就是我们所处的不可能的境地。这是一个被联合国人权理事会称犯有危害人类罪的政府，包括灭绝、谋杀、奴役、酷刑、监禁、强奸。名单还在继续。金正恩的人民正在挨饿。他们与外界隔绝。我们就忽略这一切？邀请他去白宫参加国宴？杰弗里在那个问题上坚定地站在一边。
I think the answer is you have to do it, right? That if you're not going to topple the regime-- and there would be all kinds of reasons you would not want to do that-- then you've just got to suck it up and do it. But the politics of it stink. And you can see why no president is willing to do it.
我认为答案是你必须这样做，对吧？如果你不打算推翻这个政权——而且你不想那样做会有各种各样的原因——那么你只需要忍受并去做。但其中的政治令人作呕。你可以看出为什么没有总统愿意这样做。
Yeah. That's just like-- I mean, that's just terrible.
是的。那简直就像——我的意思是，那简直太可怕了。
Yeah. Welcome to my world! So I settle for things like, hey, how about this? How about we knock off some of the military exercises and we just see if they'll stop testing nuclear weapons and missiles? How about we do that? It would just try to avoid a nuclear war for the next couple of years. And even then people are like, we can't stop military exercises. You're giving into a terrible dictator. Well, yeah, I guess I kind of am.
是的。欢迎来到我的世界！所以我满足于像这样的事情，嘿，这个怎么样？我们停止一些军事演习，看看他们是否会停止测试核武器和导弹，怎么样？我们这样做怎么样？它只是试图避免未来几年的核战争。即便如此，人们还是说，我们不能停止军事演习。你是在向一个可怕的独裁者屈服。嗯，是的，我想我确实是。
Do you think you're more comfortable with the idea of being blackmailed than other people?
你认为你比其他人更能接受被勒索的想法吗？
Yeah, of course I am. Blackmail is this very specific word that has a very specific moral connotation to it. But the reality is that the North Koreans have interests, and they are very ruthless in pursuing those interests. And as unpleasant as they are-- and they're unpleasant-- we don't have the ability to make them go away.
是的，当然。勒索是一个非常具体的词，具有非常具体的道德含义。但现实是朝鲜有利益，他们在追求这些利益时非常无情。尽管他们令人不快——他们确实令人不快——我们没有能力让他们消失。
After nuclear weapons came along in World War II, there were two views. One was that, hey, these are just bigger bombs. But the other view was, no, these are an entirely different category of weapon. You build them precisely so that no one will use them. Which is a strange idea, but it's worked so far, and presumably it would be the same with North Korea. In a way, where you stand on this issue comes down to the question, how crazy do you think Kim Jong Un is?
二战后核武器出现，有两种观点。一种是，嘿，这些只是更大的炸弹。但另一种观点是，不，这些是完全不同类别的武器。你制造它们正是为了不让任何人使用它们。这是一个奇怪的想法，但目前为止很有效，推测在朝鲜身上也会一样。在某种程度上，你在这个问题上的立场归结为这个问题，你认为金正恩有多疯狂？
Jeffrey says he does not stay up at night worrying about North Korea launching a nuclear missile at a US city. From everything he's seen, Kim Jong Un seems to be pretty rational. Ruthless and determined to stay in power, but rational. All the tests seem well-planned out, like the countries before that have pursued nuclear weapons. The Map of Death, him posing with the disco ball, that all seems very calculated, an attempt to show the world and the people of North Korea that he is in charge and he's not going away.
杰弗里说他晚上不会因为朝鲜向美国城市发射核导弹而彻夜难眠。从他所看到的一切来看，金正恩似乎相当理性。无情且决心保持权力，但理性。所有的测试似乎都计划得很好，就像之前追求核武器的国家一样。死亡地图，他拿着迪斯科球拍照，这一切看起来都经过精心计算，试图向世界和朝鲜人民表明他是负责人的，他不会离开。
Jeffrey says the real people in danger here are probably not us. It's the people stuck living in North Korea. That is another thing nuclear weapons can do. They change the diplomatic calculus in a way, I think, that means the bad guys sometimes win.
杰弗里说这里真正处于危险中的人可能不是我们。是被困在朝鲜生活的人。这是核武器可以做的另一件事。我认为它们改变了外交算计，这意味着坏人有时会赢。
David Kestenbaum is one of the producers of our program. The podcast Arms Control Wonk does seem to have at least a few listeners in North Korea. Their episode "Another North Korean Nuclear Test" was downloaded five times from there.
大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆是我们节目的制片人之一。《军备控制专家》播客在朝鲜似乎确实有几个听众。他们的剧集“又一次朝鲜核试验”在那里被下载了五次。
[MUSIC - "MARROW" BY ANI DIFRANCO]
[音乐 - 阿妮·迪弗兰科的《MARROW》]
Coming up, Jon Ronson gets real with people who are specifically paid not to get real. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，乔恩·罗森将与那些专门被花钱请来不去表现真实的人进行真实的交流。我们节目继续后，从芝加哥公共广播电台收听。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, To Be Real. We have stories about people breaking through the polite, boring, everyday fog of social acceptability and polite denial of things that none of us really want to face and getting real.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题：表现真实。我们讲述的是人们突破社会认可和礼貌否认的平庸、无聊、日常迷雾，这些迷雾是没人真正想面对的，从而实现真实的各种故事。
We have arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, The Lie Becomes the Truth.
我们已经到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，谎言变成了真理。
A couple of weeks ago, when we did an episode of our show on magicians, researching what's going on in that world, I was fascinated by a few magicians who take the premise of magic, that it's all about deception, and try to stand that on its head to get to something utterly real, unfaked, emotional, truthful.
几周前，当我们做关于魔术师的节目时，研究那个世界正在发生什么，我被几个魔术师迷住了，他们采用了魔术的前提，即一切都是关于欺骗，并试图将其颠倒过来，以获得某种绝对真实、未经伪造、情感化的、真实的东西。
There are two magicians in particular I was interested in. The first was David Blaine, who I think you might know who this is. He's been doing TV specials for 20 years. And I was hanging around Blaine one night at dinner at a restaurant, and there was this moment where a friend of his said to him something like, David, you've told me that some of your tricks these days aren't even tricks, like when you eat glass. And Blaine was like, yeah. And he picks up the nearest wine glass at the table-- this was not his glass; somebody else had been drinking out of it-- and he poured their wine into another glass on the table. And then he raised the wine glass to his mouth and bit off a chunk of the glass. And then he chewed, like, really big chews, like, chomp, chomp, chomp, chomp, chomp. And it took a little time, actually, like, chomp, chomp, chomp, chomp, chomp. And then he took a huge drink of water and he swallowed. And then he opened his mouth to show us, you know, all gone.
我特别感兴趣的是两位魔术师。第一位是大卫·布莱恩，我想你可能知道他是谁。他做了20年的电视特别节目。一天晚上我在餐馆吃晚饭时和布莱恩在一起，当时他的一个朋友对他说，大卫，你告诉过我，你这些天的一些把戏甚至不是把戏，比如你吃玻璃的时候。布莱恩说，是的。然后他拿起桌上最近的一个酒杯——这不是他的杯子；别人一直在喝——他把他们的酒倒进了桌上的另一个杯子里。然后他把酒杯举到嘴边，咬掉了一块玻璃。然后他嚼了起来，真的很大力地嚼，比如，咔嚓，咔嚓，咔嚓，咔嚓，咔嚓。这实际上花了一点时间，比如，咔嚓，咔嚓，咔嚓，咔嚓，咔嚓。然后他喝了一大口水，吞了下去。然后他张开嘴给我们看，你知道，全没了。
It's not a trick. He just eats glass, grinds it down to little specks, I guess, and swallows it. He said the inside of your mouth gets a little cut up, but it's not too bad. And there's a scene that they filmed for Blaine's most recent TV special where he's sitting in a dentist chair and he talks to his dentist about what this is doing to his teeth.
这不是魔术。他只是吃玻璃，我想他把它磨成小碎片，然后吞下去。他说你嘴巴里面会有点割伤，但还算好。在为布莱恩最近的电视特别节目拍摄的一个场景中，他坐在牙医椅上，和他的牙医谈论这对他的牙齿有什么影响。
And they're getting bad.
而且情况正在变糟。
Yes.
是的。
Because I feel hot and cold much stronger now.
因为我觉得现在对冷热的感知强多了。
Well, that's because glass is not a normal food that you're supposed to eat.
嗯，那是因为玻璃不是你应该吃的正常食物。
The dentist peers into Blaine's mouth.
牙医盯着布莱恩的嘴看。
So have you been eating this on your right side of your mouth more than your left?
所以你吃这个的时候是在你嘴的右侧比较多吗？
Yeah, only on the right side. That's so weird.
然后发生了这件有趣的事情。因为他是专业魔术师，也就是说他的工作是欺骗人，当他实际上在做这些不是魔术的惊人身体壮举时，人们往往认为它们是把戏。就像他在舞台上用嘴接住子弹——从真正的枪里射出的真正的子弹。他把它接在他含在嘴里的金属杯里，以慢动作拍摄子弹飞行的过程，拍摄他的朋友们因为他甚至试图这样做而感到不安，但仍然有些人认为，不，那不是真的。
You've worn your teeth down on the right much worse than the left.
你的牙齿右边磨损得比左边严重得多。
Wow.
哇。
Much worse.
严重得多。
Yeah, it started shifting to the right because the left was hurting so much.
是的，因为左边疼得太厉害，所以开始转向右边。
Well, your right is much worse than your left. This is totally worn away. All the enamel's gone from the tooth and his nerve is almost exposed.
嗯，你的右边比左边严重得多。这完全磨损了。牙齿上的所有牙釉质都没了，他的神经几乎暴露了。
Blaine turns to the camera crew.
布莱恩转向摄影组。
He didn't believe me--
他不相信我——
I didn't believe him, either.
我起初也不相信他。
--in the beginning.
——在开始时。
I really didn't. I didn't believe him. I've never seen anyone do it, and I thought it was a h-- I thought there was some sort of trick to it, but he's eating glass.
我真的不相信。我从未见过任何人这样做，我以为这有个什么——我以为这有什么把戏，但他真的是在吃玻璃。
So is eating glass a thing that you know that you only can do a certain number of times in your life because you'll gradually grind--
所以吃玻璃是你生命中只能做有限次数的事情吗，因为你会逐渐磨损——
Like I was saying to the dentist, every time I drink or eat everything hot and cold, it's a nightmare.
就像我对牙医说的那样，每次我喝或吃热的和冷的东西时，那都是一场噩梦。
So it's a trick like, I get to do this a certain number of times left in my life, so I've got to choose my spots.
所以这是一个像我一生中只能做有限次数的事情，所以我必须选好时机。
No. No. No, no. I still do it whenever I want.
不。不。不，不。我仍然想做的时候就做。
You still do it? Really?
你仍然在做？真的吗？
Yeah. I wouldn't really want to do with that glass because it's so thick. No, but I've done it with way thicker glasses than that. But my teeth are so bad now that I prefer wineglasses, like delicate ones.
是的。我真的不想用那个杯子，因为它太厚了。不，但我用比那厚得多的杯子做过。但我的牙齿现在太糟糕了，我更喜欢酒杯，那种精致的。
And this is the kind of magic Blaine's been cultivating for years now. He still does card tricks and all kinds of regular closeup magic, but he's also doing a bunch of effects that are like eating glass. There's no trick to it. He just really does this stuff. It's real. He was sealed in a box suspended above the Thames River for 44 days. He lived in a block of ice for over 60 hours. He held his breath for 17 minutes underwater and then explained his techniques for doing it in a Ted Talk. He works on these things for years, trains his body to do this stuff.
这就是布莱恩多年来一直在培养的魔术类型。他仍然做纸牌魔术和各种常规的近景魔术，但他也在做一系列像吃玻璃这样的效果。这没什么把戏。他真的在做这些事情。它是真实的。他曾被封在一个悬挂在泰晤士河上的盒子里44天。他在冰块里住了超过60个小时。他在水下屏住了呼吸17分钟，然后在TED演讲中解释了他的技巧。他多年来一直致力于这些事情，训练他的身体来做这些东西。
And then this funny thing happens. Because he's a professional magician, which is to say his job is to deceive people, when he's actually doing these incredible physical feats that aren't tricks, people often think they are. Like he's caught a bullet in his mouth on stage-- a real bullet fired from a real gun. He caught it in this metal cup that he held in his mouth, filmed the bullet traveling in slow motion, filmed his friends seeming actually upset with him for even trying this, and still some people think, nah, that's not real.
然后发生了一件有趣的事。因为他是一名职业魔术师，也就是说他的工作就是欺骗他人，所以当他真正做出那些并非戏法的惊人身体壮举时，人们往往以为那也是戏法。比如他在舞台上用嘴接住了一颗子弹——一颗从真枪中射出的真子弹。他用含在嘴里的金属杯接住了子弹，拍下了子弹飞行的慢动作画面，也拍下了他的朋友们因为他尝试这种事而感到真正不安的模样，可即便如此，还是有些人认为：不，那不是真的。
And there's this one moment. There's a video of this online, where Blaine makes use of this confusion over what is real and what is not real kind of brilliantly.
有这样一个时刻。网上有这段视频，布莱恩利用这种关于什么是真实、什么是虚假的困惑，表现得非常出色。
Yeah, could we just watch that together and--
是的，我们可以一起看那个然后——
Yeah.
是的。
--just narrate what's happening? Because it's such an amazing thing. Hold on.
——只是讲述发生了什么吗？因为那是如此神奇的事情。等等。
In the video, Blaine is sitting down at a little table with Ricky Gervais, the comedian and actor. And just before what I'm about to play you happens, David Blaine has shown Ricky Gervais how to do this famous trick called "needle through arm." And to be clear, that's a trick. You're not actually putting a needle through your arm. And David is like, I'm going to teach you to be a magician. And then he does the trick with Ricky Gervais' arm. So Ricky Gervais can see how you can make it look like a needle is going through your arm.
在视频中，布莱恩和喜剧演员兼演员瑞奇·热维斯坐在一张小桌子旁。就在我即将为你播放的片段发生之前，大卫·布莱恩向瑞奇·热维斯展示了如何做这个著名的“针穿手臂”的把戏。明确地说，那是个把戏。你并没有真的把针穿过你的手臂。大卫说，我要教你如何成为一名魔术师。然后他用瑞奇·热维斯的手臂做了这个把戏。所以瑞奇·热维斯可以看到你是如何让针看起来像是穿过手臂的。
OK. Then Blaine picks up a needle roughly the size of a knitting needle and starts to push the tip of it into his own arm.
好的。然后布莱恩拿起一根大约织针大小的针，开始把尖端推向自己的手臂。
See how the needle looks? See how it looks--
看针看起来怎么样？看它看起来怎么样——
Yeah.
是的。
--like it's going into the arm? You see that?
——就像它穿进手臂一样？你看到了吗？
Yeah.
是的。
So this is like a silver needle. It's like a foot-long--
所以这是一根银针。它大约一英尺长——
Stainless steel, yeah.
不锈钢，是的。
--stainless steel. And basically, the point of it is going straight--
——不锈钢。基本上，它的尖端是直的——
Through the bicep.
穿过二头肌。
--into your bicep, just the very tip of it. And Ricky Gervais is giving you this look like, wh-- wh-- wha?
——进入你的二头肌，只有它的最尖端。瑞奇·热维斯给了你那种表情，就像，哇——哇——哇？
See how it really looks--
看它真的看起来怎么样——
Yeah. Yeah, it does.
是的。是的，确实。
--like the needle is actually going--
——就像针真的在穿过——
What I love about it is the stillness of it. It's very slow and still.
我喜欢的是它的安静。它非常缓慢和静止。
[GASPS]
[喘气声]
And then he comes to life.
然后他活过来了。
Oh, n-- what the fuck? Seriously. This is mental.
哦，不——搞什么鬼？认真地。这太疯狂了。
We're seeing a needle being pushed straight through the middle of my arm.
我们看到一根针被直接推过我手臂的中间。
OK, just to be completely clear here, Blaine is actually pushing a needle through his arm for real. There's a way to do this. He's taught himself.
好的，为了完全明确，布莱恩实际上是在真的把针穿过他的手臂。有一种方法可以做到这一点。他是自学的。
But there's no blood. So it looks like a magic trick, but it doesn't make sense that it could be a magic trick because you're clearly seeing it go through the arm. And he's holding my shoulder, so I couldn't have a fake arm or a prosthetic on.
但是没有血。所以它看起来像个魔术把戏，但它不像是魔术把戏，因为你清楚地看到它穿过手臂。他正抓着我的肩膀，所以我不可能有假手臂或假肢。
What? Th-- this-- this stuff's mental.
什么？这——这东西太疯狂了。
See how it really looks--
看它真的看起来怎么样——
So-- sorry, David, seriously. Ha-- this isn't a trick.
所以——对不起，大卫，认真的。这——这不是把戏。
And so the needle is popping out the other side of your arm.
所以针正从你手臂的另一边冒出来。
How the fuck are you-- wait. What you-- what you do you mean, how are you doing it? You've stuck a needle through your fucking arm!
你怎么做到的——等等。你——你是什么意思，你是怎么做到的？你把一根针穿过了你该死的手臂！
It looks pretty real, right?
看起来相当真实，对吧？
Sorry, I don't understand. How is that not real? What do you mean it looks pretty real?
对不起，我不明白。那怎么不是真的？你说的看起来相当真实是什么意思？
It's the same as what I just did to you.
和我刚才对你做的一样。
What? This is all glue?
什么？这全是胶水吗？
What I love about this is that you're being so deadpan, but you're so happy here, you're breaking character and you start to laugh. You're having trouble not laughing all the way through this video.
我喜欢的是你表现得如此冷淡，但你在这里如此开心，你打破了角色并开始笑。你在这个视频中一直很难忍住不笑。
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
It looks really real, right?
看起来真的很真实，对吧？
Is that needle going through your arm?
那根针穿过你的手臂了吗？
Well, pull it out and you'll see how it works. Pull it.
嗯，把它拔出来，你就会明白它是怎么回事了。拔出来。
Oh, fuck me. I don't understand!
哦，操我。我不明白！
Pull.
拔。
I feel like you're seeing such a naked version of him, you know?
我觉得你看到了他如此赤裸裸的一面，你知道吗？
I don't-- that's not-- that's real. Sorry, this is real. That's real. That's not a trick. Fucking hell!
我不——那不是——那是真的。对不起，这是真的。那是真的。那不是把戏。该死！
But your stuff, I feel like more than any magician I've ever seen, I feel like when you do tricks, so much of it seems to be about getting a reaction out of the person, watching the person react to you.
但你的东西，我觉得比我见过的任何魔术师都多，我觉得当你表演把戏时，其中很大一部分似乎是为了从对方身上获得反应，看着对方对你的反应。
Yeah, and that's what I search for. That's the thing that I'm looking for more than anything is finding that unfiltered-- that person inside, basically, like the layers are all being peeled away. They're becoming, like, guard's down, vulnerable. You're seeing a real human being without the covers.
是的，这就是我所寻找的。这是我寻找的东西，比任何东西都重要，那就是找到那种未经过滤的——本质上的那个人，就像层层被剥离一样。他们变得，就像，防备放下，脆弱。你看到一个没有掩盖的真实人类。
Oh, David! What have you done? Are you a maniac? Why would you? Why would you do that?
哦，大卫！你做了什么？你是疯子吗？为什么你会？你为什么要那样做？
So Blaine loves getting that reaction from people. But interestingly, he says, when he does these physical feats, when he catches the bullet, when he holds his breath under water, when he lives in a box for weeks, he says in those moments, he feels like he's just as bare, in front of the audience, as Ricky Gervais is in that video.
所以布莱恩喜欢从人们那里得到那种反应。但有趣的是，他说，当他做这些身体壮举时，当他接住子弹，当他在水下屏住呼吸，当他在盒子里住几周时，他说在那些时刻，他觉得自己在观众面前就像瑞奇·热维斯在视频中一样赤裸。
And I think part of that is what I like about the bullet catch. It's like you're dropping all of your defenses and you're exposed in front of the audience. You're like, here's this thing. I have to do what I have to do, but I'm exposed. I'm vulnerable, and I'm not bullshitting you right now. You're watching me do something that's very real. There is no lying.
而且我认为这部分是我喜欢接子弹的原因。就像你放下了所有的防备，在观众面前暴露出来。你就像，这是这回事。我必须做我必须做的事，但我暴露了。我很脆弱，我现在没有对你撒谎。你看着我做一些非常真实的事情。没有谎言。
This is so the opposite of the way I think of magic. I think of magic as being so about creating a fake world where things are better than ours because they jump from here to there and they show up. You know what I mean? It never occurred to me of like, oh, the whole point for you would be--
这和我对魔术的看法完全相反。我认为魔术是关于创造一个虚假的世界，事物比我们的更好，因为它们从这里跳到那里，然后它们出现。你知道我的意思吗？从来没想过，哦，对你来说整个重点是——
The opposite.
相反。
--that you get to see this real, raw emotion in these people, and then, when you're doing the stunts, that they get to see that in you.
——你得以在这些人身上看到这种真实的、原始的情感，然后，当你做特技时，他们得以在你身上看到这一点。
Yeah. Yeah, it's like you're not protected. You're not covered. You're not hidden. And as a magician, you're always covered up. You're always hiding everything, right? That's what magic is. You're powerful and almighty, but to me, the interesting part of a magician is not that part. It's the exposure. It's like him being vulnerable and open in front of the audience because that's what we really care about.
是的。是的，就像你没有受到保护。你没有被覆盖。你没有被隐藏。作为一个魔术师，你总是被覆盖。你总是隐藏一切，对吧？魔术就是这样。你强大而全能，但对我来说，魔术师有趣的部分不是那部分。是暴露。就像他在观众面前变得脆弱和开放，因为这就是我们真正关心的。
Researching that magic episode, I went to see a lot of magic. David Copperfield, Penn & Teller, Criss Angel, Derren Brown, Mac King, Dan White. And my favorite thing I saw was done by a magician who, like Blaine, is trying something different with magic than most magicians do and going for something that is more real.
研究那个魔术剧集时，我看了很多魔术。大卫·科波菲尔、潘恩和泰勒、克里斯·安吉尔、德伦·布朗、麦克·金、丹·怀特。我看到最喜欢的东西是一位魔术师做的，他和布莱恩一样，正在尝试与大多数魔术师不同的东西，追求更真实的东西。
The magician's name is Derek DelGaudio. He's a close-up magician who gets awarded those prizes where magicians vote on who's the best in the world. He's invented a bunch of diabolical ways to shuffle and deal cards that give him incredible control of where cards are in the deck and let him do some mind-blowing stuff. But his new show isn't about that at all. I talked to him about it.
魔术师的名字叫德里克·德尔高迪奥。他是一位近景魔术师，获得了那些魔术师投票选出谁是世界最佳的奖项。他发明了一堆邪恶的洗牌和发牌方式，让他对牌在牌堆里的位置有令人难以置信的控制力，让他做一些令人震惊的事情。但他的新节目根本不是关于那个的。我和他谈过。
Derek's a baby-faced guy in his early 30s with a careful, precise manner on stage and off. A guy who is especially interesting to talk to when he starts complaining about stuff which he does entertainingly and well. For instance, this is him talking about how people view magic.
德里克是一个30出头、长着一张娃娃脸的家伙，在舞台上和台下都非常谨慎和精确。当他开始抱怨事情时，他是一个特别有趣的人，而且他抱怨得很生动。例如，这是他在谈论人们如何看待魔术。
There's got to be a reason that people use the word "magician" as like the highest compliment. Oh, you should taste this guy's food. He's a magician in the kitchen. Or, oh, you should see him on the basketball court. The guy's a magician out there. Oh, he's a magician. It's like, oh, Jesus, really? He's a mag-- like, an actual magician? Like, oh, god, you know?
一定有一个原因，人们用“魔术师”这个词作为最高的赞美。哦，你应该尝尝这个家伙的食物。他是厨房里的魔术师。或者，哦，你应该看看他在篮球场上的表现。那个家伙是那里的魔术师。哦，他是个魔术师。就像，哦，上帝，真的吗？他是个魔术师——就像，哦，天哪，你知道吗？
Wait. And why is that? Why is that it's a positive for everything except for actual magicians?
等等。为什么是这样？为什么这对除了真正魔术师以外的一切都是正面的？
Well, it's because a regular, traditional magic show isn't about anything other than the performer's ability to show you these things.
嗯，这是因为一个常规的、传统的魔术表演除了表演者向你展示这些东西的能力之外，什么也没有。
What he means by that is that most magic shows aren't about anything. They're just a series of amazing tricks. You do a trick. They applaud. You do another trick. They applaud. You do another trick. They applaud. And this is the thing he's trying to do differently in his new show, which is up in New York right now, called In & Of Itself. He's tried to create a show that is more than just tricks, more than people wondering how'd he do it. He's tried to create a show that's about something.
他的意思是大多数魔术表演什么都不是。它们只是一系列惊人的把戏。你做一个把戏。他们鼓掌。你做另一个把戏。他们鼓掌。你做第三个把戏。他们鼓掌。这就是他在他的新节目中试图做得不同的事情，该节目目前正在纽约上演，名叫《内在与自身》。他试图创造一个不仅仅是把戏的节目，不仅仅是人们想知道他是怎么做的。他试图创造一个关于某种东西的节目。
To achieve that, Derek doesn't even get to the first trick till eight or nine minutes in. And over the course of the show, he tells a series of stories that are sincere and personal in this way that you almost never see in any magic show. There's a story from his childhood about him and his mom. And another about something a guy said to him in a bar years ago. And another about the brief period of his life when he worked as a hustler dealing crooked poker games. All these stories are about people not seeing him as he really is.
为了实现这一点，德里克甚至在八九分钟后才进行第一个把戏。在节目过程中，他讲述了一系列真诚和个人的故事，这种方式你在任何魔术表演中几乎都看不到。有一个关于他童年时期他和妈妈的故事。另一个关于几年前在酒吧里有人对他说的话。另一个关于他生命中短暂的一段他作为骗子经营歪门邪道扑克游戏的时间。所有这些故事都是关于人们没有看到他真实的样子。
And when I say he's trying to make a show that's about something, that's what the show is actually about. It's about what it's like when people do not perceive who you really are. And my favorite moment in the show is this moment where everything he's doing comes together-- where what he's saying and the magic and what the audience goes through. And it really does feel like he's invented something new. And it gets to the kind of raw feeling David Blaine talks about wanting to achieve in his shows through very different means.
当我说他试图让一个节目关于某种东西时，这就是节目实际上关于的东西。它是关于当人们没有感知到你真实的样子时是什么感觉。我节目中最喜欢的部分是所有他做的事情融合在一起的时刻——他说的、魔术、以及观众经历的东西。它真的感觉像他发明了一些新的东西。它触及了大卫·布莱恩谈到希望通过完全不同的方式在他的节目中实现的原始感觉。
Here's what happens. Before the show, when you walk into the theater, there's a wall of cards printed with the words "I am." And then, under "I am," just different things that you might be. A baker, a gardener, troublemaker, truth-teller, the one that got away, extrovert, con artist, idealist, over 1,000 different cards. And you pick the one you feel describes yourself best and you walk to your seat. And 90 minutes later, at the end of the show about whether people see you for who you really are, Derek says to anybody who took the exercise of picking a card seriously--
发生了什么事。在演出前，当你走进剧院时，有一堵印着“我是”这两个字的卡片墙。然后，在“我是”下面，只是你可以成为的不同东西。面包师、园丁、麻烦制造者、真理追求者、那个离开的人、外向者、骗子、理想主义者，超过1000种不同的卡片。你选择一个你觉得最能描述自己的卡片，然后走向你的座位。90分钟后，在演出结束时，关于人们是否看到你真实的一面，德里克对任何认真对待挑选卡片这个练习的人说——
Maybe you chose something that you feel reflects who you really are, how you'd like to be seen in this world. If you're one of those few people, please stand up.
也许你选择了一些你觉得反映了你真实的样子、你希望在这个世界上被如何看待的东西。如果你是那少数人之一，请站起来。
It's not a big theater, about 150 seats. And on this particular night, over 100 people stand. And then Derek walks into the audience, walks up to each of those people one at a time, looks right in their eyes, and tells them what they chose.
这不是一个大剧院，大约150个座位。在这一特定的晚上，超过100人站了起来。然后德里克走进观众席，一次走到那些人中的每一个人面前，直视他们的眼睛，告诉他们选择了什么。
Boy Scout.
童子军。
The black sheep of the family.
家里的害群之马。
Black sheep of the family.
A good Christian.
一个好基督徒。
A good Christian. Watching him do this, when he tells the people sitting on your row, and the row in front of you, and the row behind you how they see themselves, it makes you look at them differently. Like, no kidding. These people who showed up on a weeknight with their backpacks and their work clothes, and suddenly you get this glimpse of something so private. It stops feeling like a room of anonymous strangers. They look different.
一个好基督徒。看着他这样做，当他告诉坐在你那排、你前面那排、和你后面那排的人他们是如何看待自己的，这让你以不同的方式看待他们。就像，没开玩笑。这些人带着背包和工作服出现在工作日的晚上，突然间你瞥见了某种如此私人的东西。它不再感觉像是一个由匿名陌生人组成的房间。他们看起来不同了。
You're a ninja.
你是忍者。
A ninja.
忍者。
You're a very good parent, aren't you?
你是一位非常好的父母，对吧？
A good parent.
好父母。
You're a ray of sunshine.
你是阳光。
A ray of sunshine.
阳光。
A wallflower.
壁花。
A wallflower. Derek told me these moments, when he walks up to people and stares in their eyes and tells them something about themselves, it's everything he was hoping the show would do. Something about those moments is not about magic. It isn't about the trick. The magic is all in service to this very human thing that's happening.
壁花。德里克告诉我这些时刻，当他走向人们并盯着他们的眼睛告诉他们关于他们自己的一些事情时，这就是他希望节目能做到的全部。关于那些时刻的某些东西与魔术无关。它与把戏无关。魔术完全是为了服务于正在发生的这种非常人性化的东西。
Yeah. I mean, I get emotional, too, just based on people's reactions to it and I see it in their eyes. And there are some that are truly painful. One stopped me in my tracks, which was someone saw themselves as a failure.
是的。我的意思是，我也变得情绪化了，只是基于人们对它的反应，我从他们的眼睛里看到了它。有一些确实令人痛苦。有一个让我停了下来，那就是有人把自己看作是一个失败者。
This was a young woman, maybe in her 20s. Derek hesitated. Then he said it. A failure.
那是一个年轻女性，大约20多岁。德里克犹豫了。然后他说出来了。失败者。
I mean, I choked up. There was a pause because you don't ever want to have to call someone a failure. And that's how they felt like they were in this world and kind of how they felt others saw them and I called them a failure in front of a bunch of strangers. But you hear-- you heard the rest of the audience go, aw.
我的意思是，我哽咽了。有一阵停顿，因为你永远不想不得不称呼某人为失败者。那就是他们觉得在这个世界上他们是什么样的人，以及某种程度上他们觉得别人怎么看他们，我在一群陌生人面前称呼他们为失败者。但你听到——你听到其余观众发出了“啊”的声音。
The woman teared up and sat down. It's the sort of moment, watching it, all you can think about is her and her life and what that must be about. What you do not think is, how'd he do it?
那个女人流下了眼泪并坐下了。那是一种观看的时刻，你只能想到她和她的生活以及那一定是什么样的。你绝对不会想的是，他是怎么做到的？
Act Three, Fly Girl. Quick warning to listeners about this next act. It's about the pornography business. There is nothing explicit in what's about to be said. In fact, it's not about sex at all. But it's about porn, so if you're listening with kids, take this as your heads up.
第三幕，飞女。给听众关于下一幕的快速警告。它是关于色情行业的。即将被说的内容中没有任何露骨的东西。事实上，它根本不是关于性。但它是关于色情的，所以如果你和孩子们一起听，把这作为你的提个醒。
The porn business is a world of fakiness-- fake bodies, fake excitement, people acting out other people's fantasies. But I heard about this one huge arena in that business where things get very, very real. I heard about it from Jon Ronson, who's on our show now and then. For over a year, he's been working on a podcast that traces how one man changed the porn industry when he aggressively applied modern internet technology-- I mean, keywords, search term optimization-- to porn, at a set of websites, including the most popular porn site in the world-- 75 million visitors a day-- called PornHub.
色情行业是一个虚假的世界——虚假的身体、虚假的兴奋、人们扮演他人的幻想。但我听说了这个行业中一个巨大的领域，在那里事情变得非常、非常真实。我是从乔恩·罗森那里听说它的，他偶尔出现在我们的节目中。一年多来，他一直致力于一个播客，追踪一个男人如何通过积极应用现代互联网技术——我的意思是，关键词、搜索词优化——改变了色情行业，在一系列网站上，包括世界上最受欢迎的色情网站——每天7500万访客——叫PornHub。
In his podcast, Jon Ronson documents all kinds of things that happened to all kinds of people because of how PornHub and this man and free porn changed pornography. And one big, obvious consequence of the success of PornHub and other free online sites is that so much pornography is given away for free. The people who make porn videos have a much harder time making a living. And one way he learned that they supplement their income is by creating custom videos. Here's Jon.
在他的播客中，乔恩·罗森记录了因为PornHub和这个男人以及免费色情内容改变了色情业而发生在各种人身上的各种事情。PornHub和其他免费在线网站成功的一个巨大而明显的后果是，太多的色情内容被免费赠送。制作色情视频的人更难维持生计。他了解到的他们补充收入的一种方式是制作定制视频。这是乔恩。
I've been on porn sites for a year, and nearly everyone I spoke with, performers and producers and crew, is also in the bespoke porn business now. They construct custom films to the detailed specifications of individual fans, contouring into life entire porn films for just one viewer. These are producers like Dan and Rhiannon of Anatomik Media. They're a married couple in their 40s, upbeat. They love their work.
我在色情网站上待了一年，我交谈过的几乎每个人，表演者、制片人和工作人员，现在也都在定制色情业务中。他们根据个别粉丝的详细规格构建定制电影，为仅仅一名观众构建出整个色情电影。这些是像Anatomik Media的丹和瑞安农这样的制片人。他们是一对40多岁的已婚夫妇，乐观向上。他们热爱他们的工作。
They send us their idea or a script, and we'll take it and tell them how much it's going to cost and what it's going to take, how long it'll take, who's available for it. And we make it for them.
他们把他们的想法或剧本发给我们，我们会拿去告诉他们要花多少钱，需要什么，需要多长时间，谁有空做。我们为他们制作。
Yeah. They're very much involved in the casting process, where we hold their hand pretty much the whole way through it.
是的。他们非常参与选角过程，我们几乎全程牵着他们的手。
Dan pulls out his laptop and deliberates on which videos to show me.
丹拿出他的笔记本电脑，考虑给我看哪些视频。
Some of them are crazy because they're just so normal. Yeah, the flyswatter.
有些很疯狂，因为它们太正常了。是的，苍蝇拍。
Oh, yes. The flyswatter.
哦，是的。苍蝇拍。
He wanted to watch a girl swatting flies.
他想看一个女孩拍苍蝇。
She remains fully clothed throughout the entire video. She's in the kitchen. And she's getting frustrated because there's flies everywhere.
她在整个视频中保持全副武装。她在厨房里。她变得很沮丧，因为到处都是苍蝇。
That really is all it is-- a woman becoming exasperated because there's a fly. And to make matters worse, she has misplaced her flyswatter.
那真的就是全部了——一个女人因为苍蝇变得气急败坏。更糟糕的是，她找不到苍蝇拍了。
So now she's looking around for a flyswatter.
所以现在她在找苍蝇拍。
She is, yes. That's the rest of the video is just swatting flies.
是的，她是。视频剩下的部分就是拍苍蝇。
Did you ask the client what it was about flyswatting?
你问过客户拍苍蝇是关于什么的吗？
Nope.
没有。
No. Sometimes you have to wonder. Maybe he watched his mom swat flies? Ooh. Probably so.
没有。有时你不得不怀疑。也许他看过他妈妈拍苍蝇？哦。很有可能。
They play me another. A woman sits in a kid's paddling pool. She's wearing a tank top and shorts and swimming goggles. She's chewing gum. And then it begins. Huge industrial-sized tubs of condiments are poured over her head. Mustard, relish, soured cream. Gallons of it.
他们给我看了另一个。一个女人坐在孩子的戏水池里。她穿着背心和短裤，戴着游泳镜。她在嚼口香糖。然后开始了。巨大的工业级调味品桶被倒在她的头上。芥末、调味酱、酸奶油。好几加仑。
[NERVOUSLY LAUGHING]
[紧张地笑]
It's like someone being slimed on Nickelodeon.
就像有人在尼克频道被泼了泥浆。
That was so much warmer than I thought it was going to be.
那比我想象的要温暖得多。
In this case, Dan and Rhiannon know a little about the man who asked for this. Well, they know one thing about him. He owns a restaurant in Georgia, where presumably he deals with mustard and ketchup every day and has to avoid situations like this.
在这种情况下，丹和瑞安农对那个提出要求的人了解一点。好吧，他们关于他只知道一件事。他在乔治亚州拥有一家餐馆，大概他每天都处理芥末和番茄酱，并且必须避免这样的情况。
Then Rhiannon gives Dan a look and says they really should play me the stamp video, which turns out to be the most intriguing of all because it raises so many questions. The client is a man in Norway that Dan and Rhiannon call Stamps Man.
然后瑞安农给了丹一个眼神，说他们真的应该给我看那个邮票视频，这结果是所有视频中最引人入胜的，因为它引发了太多的问题。客户是挪威的一个男人，丹和瑞安农称他为“邮票男”。
He has had this stamp collection for 40 years. I don't even know-- we didn't ask how much it was worth or anything. We just accepted it and burned it.
他收集邮票40年了。我甚至不知道——我们没问它值多少钱之类的问题。我们只是接受了它并把它烧了。
Burned it?
烧了？
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah. He wanted the girls--
是的。他想要女孩们——
He wanted it destroyed. He wanted the girls to have fun destroying it, and they did. And he loves it. He said he watches it every day.
他想要它被摧毁。他想要女孩们在摧毁它时玩得开心，她们确实做了。他很喜欢。他说他每天都看。
Did you ask him why-- why?
你问过他为什么——为什么吗？
No
没有。
No.
I mean, he explained a lot about how it was important to him to see these girls kind of humiliate him for having a stamp collection.
我的意思是，他解释了很多关于看到这些女孩因为他有邮票收藏而羞辱他对他有多重要。
Can we watch a bit of it?
我们可以看一点吗？
Sure.
当然。
The video fades in on a book of stamps lying on a living room floor. Three young women enter wearing school uniform. They complain about it being hot outside and wonder if they should take a shower. Then they notice the stamp collection, and one thing leads to another.
视频淡入一张躺在客厅地板上的邮票册。三个年轻女性穿着校服进来。她们抱怨外面很热，想知道是否应该洗澡。然后她们注意到了邮票收藏，事情就这样发生了。
They see his stamp collection spread out on the floor and they start making fun of it.
她们看到他的邮票收藏散落在地板上，她们开始拿它开玩笑。
[GASPS] Don't do that! Don't you dare do that! He cares about this so much.
[喘气] 不要那样做！你敢那样做！他非常在乎这个。
You know what? He would rather look at his stamp collection than have sex with me.
你知道吗？他宁愿看他的邮票收藏，也不愿和我做爱。
Well, then all the more reason to go get rid of it.
那么，更有理由去摆脱它了。
Yeah, this is stupid. Really? Stamps?
是的，这太蠢了。真的吗？邮票？
One of the women starts stomping on the stamps.
其中一个女人开始踩邮票。
He wanted that specifically.
他特别想要那个。
Wait till they get to the fire.
等到她们用到火的时候。
So you sure you don't want to burn at least one page?
所以你确定你不想至少烧掉一页？
Burn it?
烧掉它？
Say goodbye, stamps, baby.
说再见，邮票，宝贝。
Bye, stamps.
再见，邮票。
In real life, these girls, actually they felt sort of bad about it. They felt really bad. But we kept trying to assure them, no, this is really what he wants.
在现实生活中，这些女孩，她们其实觉得有点糟糕。她们觉得非常糟糕。但我们一直在试着向她们保证，不，这真的是他想要的。
Burn! Burn! Burn! Burn!
烧！烧！烧！烧！
After several months emailing Stamps Man, we finally managed to convince him to tell us his story. It turns out that, after years obsessively collecting stamps and spending way too much money on it, he started to feel depressed and isolated. So he went to see a psychologist who told him stamp collecting is a ridiculous hobby because it's so solitary. And so now he pays porn people to destroy his stamps. He says he's had 10 books of stamps, and he's been destroying them in this way one at a time. And he's only got one book left, he says. He's deciding which custom producer to send it to. And after that, he's all done.
几个月后给“邮票男”发邮件，我们终于设法说服他告诉我们他的故事。事实证明，在痴迷收集邮票并为此花费太多钱多年后，他开始感到沮丧和孤立。所以他去看了一位心理学家，心理学家告诉他邮票收集是一种荒谬的爱好，因为它是如此孤独。所以现在他付钱给色情人员摧毁他的邮票。他说他有10本邮票，他一直以这种方式一次摧毁一本。他说他只剩下最后一本了。他正在决定把它寄给哪个定制制片人。在那之后，他就全完了。
I thought I was done, too. I thought I'd learned all there was to learn about custom videos. But then I heard one more time from Dan and Rhiannon. Something had happened. They'd just received an email.
我觉得我也完了。我以为我已经学到了关于定制视频所能学到的一切。但后来我再次从丹和瑞安农那里听到了消息。发生了一些事。他们刚刚收到一封电子邮件。
It was about 4:00 or 5:00 AM. Dan received the email and read it.
大约是凌晨4:00或5:00。丹收到了那封邮件并读了它。
I kind of wanted to wake her up and show her because it's the most unique request we've had.
我有点想叫醒她给她看，因为这是我们收到过的最独特的要求。
The email was requesting a porn star to sit cross-legged on the floor, fully clothed, and say into the camera, you are loved. Things are bad now, but they won't always be. Suicide is not the answer.
邮件要求一个色情明星交叉双腿坐在地板上，全副武装，对着镜头说，你被爱着。现在情况很糟糕，但不会永远这样。自杀不是答案。
It was just really heavy. And I wanted to make sure he's OK.
这真的很沉重。我想确保他没问题。
We basically handled it like a normal request and gave him model options and everything like that and told them we can shoot it really soon. And we haven't heard back.
我们基本上像对待正常要求一样处理它，给了他模特选项之类的一切，并告诉他们我们可以很快拍摄它。然后我们没收到回音。
Dan and Rhiannon decided to shoot it anyway and send it to him.
丹和瑞安农还是决定拍摄它并寄给他。
The location that we're going to shoot at, there's so much natural light and it's up on the top of the hill, and the blue sky and everything, and everything is white-- white marble, white curtains, just bright white and brilliant. I don't know. We want it to just look beautiful.
我们要拍摄的地方，有很多自然光，它在山顶上，蓝天什么的，一切都是白色的——白色大理石，白色窗帘，只是明亮的白色和灿烂。我不知道。我们只想让它看起来很美。
It's the day of the shoot. Dan and Rhiannon and the porn performer, Riley Reyes, convene at the location. It's a sitting room in a mansion. There's a window facing a mountain and the valley and, probably because of all the recent rains in LA, everything outside is verdant. It looks like heaven from a film.
拍摄日。丹和瑞安农以及色情表演者莱利·雷耶斯在那个地点集合。这是一座豪宅里的客厅。有一扇对着山谷和山脉的窗户，大概因为洛杉矶最近所有的雨水，外面的东西都是青翠的。它看起来像电影里的天堂。
Riley is 28. She's wearing bright pink jeggings and a bright blue tank top.
莱利28岁。她穿着亮粉色打底裤和亮蓝色背心。
Do you mind if I read the email?
你介意我读这封邮件吗？
Oh, not at all. That's-- absolutely.
哦，一点也不。那——绝对是。
Dan and Rhiannon aren't charging the man. I'll call him Milo. They're not charging him for obvious reasons. And also because he still hasn't responded to their email. But they are paying Riley just like they would in a normal custom shoot. Riley is nervous.
丹和瑞安农没向那个男人收费。我会叫他米洛。他们没向他收费是有明显原因的。而且也是因为他仍然没有回复他们的邮件。但他们确实像在正常定制拍摄中一样给莱利报酬。莱利很紧张。
Are you OK?
你还好吗？
Mhm. Yeah. It's just that I think lots of people have lost friends this way, right? So it makes me think-- I hope he likes it. OK. I'm going to gather myself.
嗯。是的。只是我想很多人都以这种方式失去了朋友，对吧？所以它让我想到——我希望他喜欢它。好的。我要集中心思。
That's OK. Do whatever you need, sweet pea.
没关系。做你需要做的任何事，甜心。
I think it's safe to say that most people needing comfort wouldn't reach out to custom fetish porn producers, who the outside world might think of as cynical operators. But having been here a year, it makes so much sense to me. Custom producers are kind of like a family of outsiders themselves, and they often respond to their clients in the most sincere and heartfelt ways.
我认为可以肯定地说，大多数需要安慰的人不会联系定制恋物色情制片人，外界可能会认为他们是愤世嫉俗的操作者。但在这里待了一年，这对我来说很有意义。定制制片人本身有点像局外人的家庭，他们经常以最真诚和衷心的方式回应他们的客户。
Let's do it.
我们开始吧。
OK. Camera ready. Yes?
好的。相机准备好了。是吗？
[CLAPPER]
[场记板]
Action.
动作。
It's Riley. You're going to be OK. It might not be great for a little bit, but it's all going to turn out OK. Life has its ups and downs. I've been low. I've been really low. I've-- I've thought about dying in the past. And at the time, it seemed-- it seemed like the only thing that made any sense. But I came back up out of the ashes, and I came back stronger. And every day now, I'm able-- able to see these little bits of beauty in the world around me and in the people who open their hearts to me. And that's-- and that's what's worth it.
我是莱利。你会没事的。可能会有一段时间不太好，但一切都会好起来的。生活有起有落。我也低落过。我曾经非常低落。我——我过去想过死。当时，它似乎——它似乎是唯一有意义的事情。但我从灰烬中又站了起来，我站起来时更坚强了。现在每天，我都能——能看到我周围世界和那些向我敞开心扉的人身上的一点点美。那就是——那就是值得的地方。
Soon they'll send this video to Milo, even though they've heard nothing from him. It's a leap of faith. Everyone's just hoping that he doesn't do this to get off on it in some way. Everyone is also hoping that the reason why he's gone quiet is just because he's regretful or embarrassed or he's changed his mind. But then the video will arrive, and he'll watch it and maybe, in some small way, it will help.
很快他们就会把这段视频发给米洛，尽管他们没从他那里听到任何消息。这是信任的飞跃。每个人都只是希望他不是为了某种方式得到释放而这样做。每个人也希望他沉默的原因只是因为他后悔、尴尬或改变了主意。但视频会到达，他会看它，也许，以某种微小的方式，它会有所帮助。
Stick with us.
请继续收听。
[KISSES]
[吻声]
Jon Ronson. That story produced by Lina Misitzis with original music by Joel Ronson. The brand-new podcast that it's part of, an audible original series called The Butterfly Effect, will premiere at the end of July. You can preorder right now at audible.com/butterflyeffect.
乔恩·罗森。那个故事由莉娜·米西齐斯制作，原创音乐由乔尔·罗森提供。它所属的全新播客，一个名为《蝴蝶效应》的Audible原创系列，将于7月底首映。你现在可以在audible.com/butterflyeffect预订。
[MUSIC - CHERYL LYNN, "GOT TO BE REAL"]
[音乐 - 雪莉·琳恩的《GOT TO BE REAL》]
Well, our program was produced today by Stephanie Foo. Our staff includes Elna Baker, Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Chana Joffe-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Seth Lind, Jonathan Menjivar, BA Parker, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Diane Woo. Our senior producer is Brian Reed.
好吧，我们的节目今天由斯蒂芬妮·富制作。我们的员工包括埃尔娜·贝克、苏珊·伯顿、本·卡尔洪、佐伊·蔡斯、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆、塞思·林德、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、BA帕克、罗宾·塞米恩、艾丽莎·希普、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和黛安·吴。我们的高级制片人是布莱恩·里德。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
David Blaine is touring with all kinds of physical feats like we talked about in Act Two today. To see when he's coming to your town, davidblaine.com. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
大卫·布莱恩正在巡演各种身体壮举，就像我们今天在第二幕讨论的那样。要查看他何时来到你的城市，访问davidblaine.com。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交易所交付给公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, I told him, the way I see it, I won't have to start thinking about, your know, Botox or any other aging stuff for a couple of years, at least. And he said--
像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，我告诉过他，照我看，我至少几年内不必开始考虑什么肉毒杆菌或其他抗衰老的东西。他说——
Uh, I don't think you've got a couple of years, chief.
呃，我不认为你有几年时间，头儿。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。